que david libeskind merci d'être avec
nous david livet skin avocat proche
d'eads et gilet jaune nous en défense tu
es certain votre réaction déjà sur ses
peines
alors évidemment je n'ai pas participé à
ce procès en tant qu'avocat donc je
mettrais quand même 10 des réserves
puisque gpu et axone là où vraiment je
peux me prononcer quand ça concerne le
plus jeune je crois qu'il avait 21 ans
qui a été condamné à 6 sévèrement parce
qu'il n'avait pas de casier judiciaire
son casier était vierge donc il a été
condamné quand même à deux ans de prison
dont 18 mois avec sursis
donc cette peine ne me paraît quand même
assez disproportionnée pour quelqu'un en
fait qu'il n'a pas de qu'il n'a pas le
cas des musiciens judiciaire c'est pas
la pratique judiciaire normal qu'on
connaît nous avocats au quotidiennement
généralement une personne qui n'a pas de
casier
dès lors qu'il ya pas de préjudice
corporel d'ailleurs qu'il ya pas une
victime qui a été blessé mais jamais
condamné une peine de prison ferme
ça veut dire quoi qu'en gros il fallait
en faire des exemples de ces personnes
bien sûr il fallait en faire des
exemples puisque qui déjà bon faut voir
le contexte c'était début décembre 2018
c'est vrai que décembre 2018 il c'était
l'effervescence 1 il y avait beaucoup de
violence d'ailleurs que faire la demande
et du mouvement là c'était le début du
mouvement effectivement il y avait des
violences mais autant de la part de
manifestants que des forces de l'ordre
donc il y avait une très grande
effervescence
il faut voir ce contexte particulier
ensuite voilà condamner des personnes à
des peines de prison ferme qui n'ont
repas quasi je ne pense pas que c'est
très serré c'est l'outil pédagogique 1
je veux dire c'est par ces par rendre
service à la personne qui est condamné
puis c'est pas ça donne pas à mon sens
une bonne image
la justice c'est pas du tout équitable
alors justement quand vous parler
d'équité
beaucoup d'observateurs donc pas pu
s'empêcher de faire le parallèle avec
les policiers qui eux sont jugés pour
des actes violents et également est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment en tant
qu'avocat je parle rarement de sentiment
en tant qu'avocat mais de deux fait un
factuellement est-ce que vous votre
impression on en revient à l'impression
finalement c'est que les policiers les
gie des gens ne sont sont traités de la
même manière
maintenant il ya un traitement qui est
vraiment différenciée qui n'est pas
admissible vous rendez compte que un
policier
qui blesse une personne puisqu'on l'a vu
dans votre vote reportage il se prend 4
mhz avec sursis alors qu'il a blessé
sept personnes
alors que le policier en fait doit
donner l'exemple puisqu'il représente
l'état les fonctionnaires et de l'autre
côté en plus et de l'autre côté en fait
un simple citoyen de 21 ans qui n'a pas
de casier se prend désormais présents
dont il ya quand même une différence de
traitement qui quiconque qui a faim
qu'on ne peut pas tolérer le le
fonctionnaire de police est là pour
donner le temps et en plus il continue à
exercer le fait justement qu'il soit
dans sa fonction dans le cadre dont
l'exercice de sa fonction est ce que ça
peut être quand même une circonstance
justement atténuantes et alléger les
peines non ça devrait être une
circonstance aggravante ce qu'il doit
donner l'exemple ans a quitté policiers
ils étaient formés ou au maintien à la
gestion du maintien de l'ordre
il a été formé à tout ça donc il peut
pas comme ça sous le coup d'une
impulsion frapper un manifestant alors
ça parle du d'être il n'est pas du tout
en légitime défense
donc la peine devrait être plus sévère à
l'encontre du policier le lissier qui
n'ont pas toujours été bien formé un de
leurs aveux même est ce que justement on
peut tenir un agent responsable de ce
type de sion qu'il ne faut pas aller
chercher plus haut dans la hiérarchie
selon vous oui alors faut peut-être
aller chercher plus haut en fait les
donneurs d'ordre puisque qui dit en fait
aux policiers qui sont sur le terrain
de taper des manifestants c'est des
instructions qui viennent d'en haut
d'après on peut pas à chaque fois des
records attendait il n'a pas été il a
été mal formés donc c'est pas de sa
faute non on peut on peut pas avoir cet
esprit dit s'est engagé dans la police
donc il doit maîtriser il doit se
maîtriser il va avoir un sang-froid qui
dix fois plus élevé qu'à manifestante
donc c'est pas du tout là aucune excuse
est-ce que selon vous david habib et
sting ses concerts en l'occurrence celui
ci qui est l'un des premiers un soutien
dans des conditions optimums on imagine
la pression et la symbolique politique
de ces jugements comment va faire face
les juges justement alors si c'est la
conférence procès y avait une symbolique
puisque c'est la préfecture alors la
preuve qu'il ya l'avocat qui dit je
crois que c'est un avocat des parties
civiles qui a dit vous avez touché à la
démocratie en l'incendiant une petite
partie avec la préfecture
non c'est pas la préfecture n'est pas le
symbole de la démocratie c'est le
symbole de l'état puisque le préfet
représente l'état dans les régions ou
les départements alors effectivement il
ya un symbole qui est plus que politique
puisque je rappelle que les préfets sont
nommés par décret présidentiel et qu'ils
obéissent aux instructions du du
ministère de l'intérieur qui a interdit
ces manifestations il dirige aussi
notamment à paris une partie des forces
de l'ordre donc évidemment c'est on a
voulu être sévère parce que en fait
la préfecture est un symbole politique
alors vous parlez préfet le préfet
justement didier lallement est au coeur
de révélations dans des notes que le cip
le site mediapart s'est procuré des
hauts gradés de la gendarmerie nationale
et des crs alertes sur des pratiques
jugées illégales de ce prêt faire du
profit de préfet de police de paris
ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
étonne et qu'elles n'entrent l'exemple
d'un anneau g bâle je suis pas du tout
étonné puisque moi-même j'ai j'ai
défendu le foxy lellouche qui est une
figure du mois du mouvement des jeunes
qui avaient à plusieurs fois déclarée en
fait une manifestation avec la
préfecture qui a été interdite et à la
fin de cette magnifique
enfin là à la fin du rassemblement il a
été mis en garde à vue deux fois
organisation d'une manifestation
interdite et le dossier était classé
sans suite deux fois donc si vous voulez
le ce que fait le préfet s'est lassé de
la répression politique qui ciblent des
gens des figures comme fauzy lelouch ou
d'autres mamans la luge et jérôme ont
envoyé à plusieurs reprises être entouré
encadré menacé par des policiers alors
qu'il ne faisait rien de particulier il
circulait dans la rue
voilà donc faut prendre des sanctions à
l'encontre du préfet parce que ce qui
est dit en fait dans ce rapport et à
extrêmement gras ça ne fait en fait que
confirmer le sentiment qu'ils avaient
les manifestants à l'égard du duduk raf
et de de positif de parts et instruments
qui instrumentalisent les forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain pendant les
manifestations de manière à ce que en
fait ils commettent alors gérer pas
jusqu'à quoi voulez bien physiquement au
tournant tout cas des violences
psychologiques à l'encontre des
manifestants
vous rendez compte que les
manifestations pour tuer la
manifestation mais ils s'appellent les
violences psychologiques qui sont
également puni par le par le code pénal
le fait de systématiquement menacé des
manifestants sans sauce sans raison
particulière
c'est une infraction c'est une
infraction on peut menacer les gens
quand ils risquent de trouver leur
public
et on a vu que depuis son entrée en
fonction non c'est pas le premier cas
nasser l'ancien préfet le faisait
également mais là il est là quand même
la mobilisation des jeunes a quand même
baissé par rapport à l'année dernière où
par rapport à la fin 2010 8 et les nas
continue voilà les menaces continues et
inas les manifestants alors que les
manifestations ne sont pas terminés et
l'heure n'est pas venue de voilà pour
les manifestants de rentrer chez eux
quoi merci en tout cas david à libé de
skins d'être venu en direct sur rt
france